vamos a explorar un poquito más esta
idea de no utilizar oro en bruto para
realizar pagos para bienes y servicios
vamos a regresar al ejemplo y voy a
dibujar la hoja de balance un poco más
en limpio construye un edificio verdad
mi banco mi bóveda como quieras llamarlo
para esto utilice 100 piezas de oro vale
entonces esto de aquí es la hoja de
balance del banco de sal
aquí tenemos 100 piezas de oro y claro
cuando dijo 100 piezas de oro pues estoy
aquí es el capital de jaén lo marco
capital ahora no es como que realmente
tenga 100 piezas de oro ahorita no están
en la bóveda ni nada las utilice para
pagarle a los constructores de este
templo romano ellos se lo llevaron
digamos fuera de la aldea entonces
simplemente estoy diciendo que tengo 100
piezas de oro en un edificio porque si
vendiera ese edificio entonces tal vez
me pagarían si empiezan a oro por eso
digo que las tengo pero bueno eso no es
el punto de este vídeo el punto es que
construí mi banco le platiqué a todas
las personas que habría un banco y las
intenté convencer de que de que entraran
y digamos que no sé qué ciudadano a dice
suena como una muy buena idea el banco
se ve padre el templo está bonito confió
en sal y en todos sus antepasados y por
tanto es buena idea depositar dinero en
ese banco y voy a depositar 500 piezas
de oro entonces al depositar las se
convierte en un activo y en un pasivo
para mi banco deja de poner a la
izquierda el activo como más bonito
posible quedó un poco chueco pero creo
que se ve la idea verdad el ancho no es
tan importante la altura más o menos es
la cantidad y entonces aquí le voy a
escribir que digamos mi tío depósito 500
piezas de oro en el banco porque esta
bóveda se ve muy segura y le pregunto a
mi tío quieres todo en tu cuenta de
cheques o quieres un poquito de efectivo
entonces él dice pues suena que es una
buena idea tener efectivo porque voy a
poder comprar mi despensa y pagar mis
clases de piano no sé lo que sea
entonces vamos a poner 400 en la cuenta
de cheques déjame dibujarlo por aquí
en la cuenta sabes que deja de poner
primero el efectivo acá abajo entonces
supongamos que quiere 100 de esos 500 en
efectivo va entonces al pedir 100 en
efectivo
yo voy a emitir notas bancarias
equivalentes a 100 piezas notas
bancarias pendientes para entonces
supongamos que estas notas bancarias no
se le doy cinco notas bancarias de 20 va
casi todos los cajeros hacen eso ahorita
berra pide 100 te dan 5 de 20 ahora no
quiero confundir las cosas ahorita
recuerda que esto de aquí es mi mundo
ficticio y no necesariamente son pesos
esto de aquí son notas bancarias del
banco de sal que si tienes una de esas y
vas al banco entonces te da la cantidad
de piezas de oro que diga la nota
bancaria es lo único que dice y claro
son bien difíciles de falsificar verdad
porque pues no quiero que nadie imprima
esas en su casa y se lleve mi oro
simplemente quiero intercambiarlas si yo
las imprimir pero bueno ese esa persona
que depositó pidió 100 piezas de oro en
efectivo ya se las di y el resto va a
querer que se ponga en su cuenta de
cheques
ok entonces en su cuenta de cheques eso
de ahí es un pasivo para mí pues puede
pedirme ese dinero cuando quiera
entonces son 400 piezas de oro en la
cuenta de cheques de a muy bien cuenta
de cheques ya eso es un pasivo es un
pasivo para mí ni siquiera están mis
activos muy bien luego alguien más que
es de confianza de a digamos ve oye
maravillas acerca de esto del banco y
dice es una muy buena idea voy a
depositar parte de mi dinero entonces
pues no sé a lo mejor ve no tiene tanto
dinero pero se anima a depositar y
digamos que ve tiene 200 piezas de oro
que quiere meter al banco voy a hacer el
lado izquierdo primero que quede bien
derechito a ver lo voy a poner algo así
y 200 piezas de oro para la persona ve
ahí se ve como de 200 mil 200 piezas de
oro y digamos que pide la mitad en
efectivo y la mitad en su cuenta de
cheques
entonces voy a dibujarlo de esta manera
entonces la mitad
piezas de oro
las voy a meter en su cuenta de cheques
y la otra mitad las otras 100 piezas de
oro se las voy a dar en efectivo en
notas bancarias
ahí le voy a poner supongamos que lo
pide todo en notas bancarias de 10 o sea
haber 100 piezas de oro en notas
bancarias pendientes no en vez de 10
vamos a pensar que que quiere nos en
notas de 1 porque le encanta el peso del
dinero entonces van a ser 100 notas de 1
verdad entonces le vamos a dar 100 notas
y cada una vale una pieza de oro una
pieza de oro una pieza de oro ahí está
mi cara muy bien todo muy bonito baja
entonces vamos a pensar un poquito en
cómo pueden ocurrir transacciones en
este mundo específicamente entre a y b
supongamos que ale quiere comprar había
una manzana ustedes voy a dibujar esto
mejor acá arriba no mejor abajo para que
no se me acabe el espacio entonces
supongamos que a y b están en la
siguiente situación a tiene hambre y ve
tiene una manzana voy a dibujar la
manzana
ahí está la manzana debe muy bien
entonces mi dibujito y a dice yo quiero
comprar tu manzana en cuanto a la vendes
y ve dice pues te la vendo en dos piezas
de oro
y la persona dice pues está un poquito
caro pero está bien tengo hambre te voy
a dar dos piezas de oro pero sabes que
ahí está nueva cosa que se llama un
banco ahorita no tengo piezas de oro
contantes y sonantes en vez de esto
déjame darte un papelito de del banco de
sal que dice que puedes ir a
intercambiarlo por piezas de oro
entonces me dice está muy bien sí sí yo
ya estoy familiarizado con el banco
hagamos eso entonces la persona a
personalidad
tenía billetes de 20 verdad a lo mejor
ya consiguió cambio o el cajero le dio
billetes más chiquitos no sé supongamos
vamos a poner que es todo son billetes
de un peso bueno de una pieza de oro y
ahorita ya estoy confundiendo de pesos
con piezas de oro pero no importa pues
supongamos que si son 20 vamos a ponerle
20 para hablar un poquito de cambio
entonces le da uno de estos billetes o
notas bancarias de 20 la pongo en verde
porque así lo había puesto se la da a ve
de esta nota bancaria de 20 ave que le
da a la manzana aa
y además le tiene que dar cambio verdad
le tiene que dar este pues 18 notas
bancarias de una pieza de oro
de estas notas que obtuvo al abrir su
cuenta entonces le da 18 de estas notas
bancarias va entonces en el fondo de
esta transacción se intercambiaron dos
piezas de oro en notas bancarias y una
manzana ahora observa aquí cuando
hicimos esta transacción no tuvimos por
qué utilizar oro ni nada verdad fue muy
práctico pudimos dar cambio exacto
verdad en esta situación imagínate un
mundo en donde pues el oro es la unidad
de intercambio y se tiene que pagar en
oro una cosa muy cara que necesita
cambio pues partir el oro en cachos
chiquitos es un lío aquí con los
billetes como la unidad es muy pequeña
nos ayuda a dar cambio exacto de hecho
pues puedes pensar un mundo en donde la
menor unidad de en otras bancarias es
más chiquita que la menor unidad de oro
y eso ayuda muchísimo para pagar cosas
fraccionarias verdad es más fácil que
cortar y volver a unir el oro ahora
estas notas se siguen intercambiando
conforme se tengan que hacer
transacciones el banco se olvida tantito
de estas preocupaciones el oro
en las bóvedas todo está muy bien vamos
a otra compra supongamos que la persona
ve quiere comprar algo de la persona
algo muy grande supongamos que quiere
comprar
a ver la persona ve y la persona no
sabes que como la persona tiene más
dinero ella va a ser la que le compra
algo grande ave supongamos que ve es un
arquitecto bat ve es un arquitecto y la
persona adquiere una casa va con bay
dice sabes que quiero una casa quiero
que me diseñan y construyen una casa
entonces te voy a pagar 200 piezas de
oro para que me dice que si construyes
la casa pero no quiero andar cargando
eso qué te parece si te escribo un
cheque y belice bueno va pero que es un
cheque entonces a 16 sabes que fue un
cheque es una nota que da la orden al
banco de transferir esa cantidad de
dinero que está a mi nombre para que
esté a tu nombre y venirse a avs eso
suena muy bien son demás súper padre que
le da a una casa trabaja diseña contrata
albañiles lo que sea le da a su casa y
luego la persona le tiene que pagar
entonces le escribió un cheque y pues
vamos a los cheques un cheque también va
a ser un pedazo de papel que se va a ver
así la persona va a llenar ciertos datos
en el cheque va a escribir su nombre va
a poner la cantidad que son doscientas
piezas de oro y lo va a firmar
bueno también le pone fecha 10/08/10 de
agosto ya que llenó los datos se lo da a
ven bbva al banco ya que va al banco le
enseña el papel y el banco base la
transacción simplemente va a cambiar 200
de a ave entonces lo único que tiene que
hacer el banco es lo siguiente de estas
400 piezas que están en la cuenta de
cheques de a agarra la mitad y las pone
a nombre bebé entonces ahora este sería
el cacho debe cuanto es saber es 100 más
200 serían 300 piezas de oro
muy bien en la parte de a por supuesto
acaba de disminuir a esta parte de aquí
y observa que el banco simplemente tuvo
que hacer un poquito de trámites 200
piezas de oro para hacer esta
transacción eso estuvo útil porque no
tuvo que emitir efectivo antes habíamos
hablado de que de que el oro era un
poquito peligroso tenerlo porque podrían
robarlo pero algo parecido pasa con el
efectivo el peligro con el efectivo es
que también es probable no hay nadie que
esté manteniendo un registro de quién
tiene que billetes y eso hace como que
es difícil saber si el dinero es robado
o no por otro lado qué pasa con los
cheques los cheques son más padres
porque puedes pagar grandes cantidades
de dinero y solo y claro si estamos
haciendo la la autenticación bien solo
la persona puede escribir el cheque
tiene un mundo ideal no tendría sentido
robar una chequera de alguien y firmar
cheques porque el banco debe tener en
sus registros la firma de las personas y
entonces tiene que verificar los cheques
y consultar con cualquier cosa
sospechosa en fin esta fue una breve
introducción a las notas bancarias y a
los cheques en el siguiente vídeo lo que
quiero hacer es ver cómo estás nociones
sirven también para hacer préstamos
el oro salga nunca de las bóvedas nos
vemos